[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right mic check mic check good
morning good evening good afternoon
to our Global audience you guys are all
over the place so
wherever you may be watching from
whatever time of day it may be
thank you for being here hanging out
with us
people of the internet
Metro record sewer here I'm just a dad
who loves games and the stories they
tell and guys ladies and Gentlemen The
Vibes man they're they're at an all-time
high right now 10 out of 10.
10 out of 10 folks because we are
getting ready to watch a brand new
Hogwarts Legacy gameplay showcase uh I
think the rumor I saw was that it's
supposed to be apparently if the Reddit
not hackers but
um people who kind of looked at the code
and stuff I think it's supposed to be
around 35 36 minutes long we'll see if
those are correct welcome to Gryffindor
so how's everybody doing today man how's
everybody doing
hold on we just had a whole bunch of
members pop through right there
we just had a whole bunch of members by
the way land of Hogwarts good to see you
here I know our normal stream time land
of Hogwarts can never make those so
there's probably a lot of people in here
who don't get to normally watch because
of our late streaming time
so welcome to all of you let's see okay
somebody just gifted out a bunch of
memberships who was it
oh dude we have wait wait
holy oh no hold on hold on we had three
back to back to back
so I think I think Elwyn gotta started
off here with five gifted memberships
elwin a member of House rack and tour
moderator of the stream as well
moderator over on the Discord uh so five
of you received oh my God
oh my goodness I can't keep up okay so
we're just there's no way we're gonna
have time to say all the names uh for
those of you who got gifted anyway
congrats on the gifted memberships make
sure you thank the person who gifted you
uh use those emotes today's gonna be a
great day to use those emotes guys lots
of good Wizarding World emotes that we
have there so you can use those anywhere
on the channel even watching videos as
well uh then right after Elwyn our boy
Dylan coming in with the five gifted
memberships Dylan elwin both members of
house wreck and tour thank you all so
much for the gifted memberships uh and
then just this is just gonna be going
like crazy here oh man all right so then
right after Dylan we had Nico all
members of power strike into are all
three moderators by the way guys
all three of these moderators here of
the stream uh so Nico with five Dylan
with five Elwyn with five and then right
after that retro guy gaming with five
gifted memberships you're also not
subject to slow mode when you have a
membership by the way guys so get ready
here there's the chat's gonna be moving
quick today
I have no doubt about that chat is going
to be moving very quickly
and then not to be outdone
following up
the five the five the five the five then
we have Noob jumping in there with 10
gifted memberships let's go man what a
way to start the live stream here
what a way to start the stream today
looks like the uh Hogwarts I can see
countdown has an 11 minutes we'll go
ahead and get the scene switched over
here in a bit uh and I will definitely
have to disable alerts I just realized
Griffith we will definitely need to turn
off the alerts actually let me go ahead
and do that now for the next scene that
we're gonna pull up because we don't
want as much as we love the the great
support here
we don't want that going off we're right
in the middle of our
of the gameplay showcase right all right
so I need to go to my overlays yeah
let's just do this one here
and I think we'll just need to turn that
off right there there we go so we'll
keep we'll keep this screen up for now
so any of the alerts that come through
will show up Noob oh man why did noobs
not show the little image
how are you see just when you think we
have it fixed there you go all right
let's say hello to everyone in the chat
guys thank you so much for all of the
the gift that's there to start the
Stream
welcome or division here in the house we
got Tom Snipes here Jay Rossi here as
well Atomic dudman welcome Atomic dead
man
uh so to be a member let me see if this
uh let's see if if nightbot is doing
their job today come on nightbot come on
there you go night bot there you go
exclamation point join let you know
Stargazer Tim member of House wreck and
tour another moderator in the house
today Tim good to see you my friend
how are you Alicia here as well Panda
sniper good to see Panda sniper here
pineapple Sam go ninja go two members of
house wrecking tour right there
uh let's see Krista here little picket
is back again welcome back little
Piggott land of Hogwarts land of
Hogwarts got one of the gifteds let's go
land of Hogwarts I always see you in the
replay Squad always see you in the
replay Squad definitely appreciate your
support there
all right so we have let's see T minus
uh nine minutes how are you according to
the official Hogwarts Legacy post right
there
don't let Mary Studio says what don't
want alerts going off yeah once the
gameplay showcase actually starts
we'll want all of the alerts to be you
know completely muted out while that's
happening
let's see oh my goodness we got so many
members hanging out today let's see
Maddie bendy is here Gallifrey William
is here with a channel member Draco is
back once again
I I agree dude we the community is
incredible incredible Tom Snipes I show
sped uh D Bama swag oh we got a Bama fan
in here we got a Bama fan it's all good
it's all good they're a great team a
great team Trevor Morris is here in the
house as well
the reason I kind of pause at that one
Bama swag hopefully you don't leave the
stream after this but I'm I'm originally
from Tennessee so
still still a Tennessee fan but it's all
good it's all good uh land of Hogwarts
let's see Natasha Ford
Simeon Dean Wiggins
Let's see we already said Tom Tom's
AutoCAD Studio One of the gifted members
as well we got Lucas in the house
welcome welcome guys
it's gonna be a fun day it's gonna be a
really really fun day
uh like I was saying in the intro for
those of you just jumping in maybe
didn't hear uh the rumor is that it's
going to be around 36 minutes long or so
well
and we're getting a look at
broom flight and traversal this is the
confirmed stuff we're getting to look at
broom flight and traversal Advanced
combat
and introduction to the room of
requirements so those are the big three
right there
vibrating Taco just finally like two
months ago watch your vids never caught
a stream before hey well glad you got to
catch a stream see we normally stream
Tuesday evenings around 8 P.M eastern
time so for those of you who can make
that that's usually when we do our live
streams but we have such a worldwide
audience I know the timing doesn't
always work for everyone so
yo Casey Lawrence how's it going Casey
Casey jumping in with a super chat just
joined the Discord
Casey that's awesome I know Casey I know
you were saying you're a little bit
hesitant so you know take it slow you
don't have to jump right in right I mean
I honestly I don't even get to chat in
the Discord nearly as much as I would
like to nearly as much
um did you say six minutes no uh 36
minutes Tom 36 minutes is the rumored
length there were some folks on um on
the Reddit saying that they had checked
the
I don't know some kind of like code
behind the scenes code on YouTube that
would show I don't know so we'll see if
they're right uh saying six minutes to
go and let's see we just got a okay yeah
we got that super chat nice nice
hope I'm the next guest host I mean
we'll see I don't I don't think um
I don't know I'm kind of thinking
probably not because I feel like
something would have already happened by
now just because of um how far in
advance they've been recording these I
know James recorded his way back not not
really sure when Ben recorded his
exactly but I mean because it's already
mid-December so yeah I mean it'd be
awesome but nothing nothing at this time
so we'll see we'll see and we got it's
saying six minutes so just so we don't
miss anything I'm gonna go ahead and
switch over
um so guys if you if you do a super chat
or become a member or anything during
this time it won't pop up my apologies
just because of the scene that we are
switching over to here but uh you should
still see your name go across at the
bottom Alicia with a two dollar Super
Chat as well shout out to my friend Illy
or maybe is it Lily or Illy
joining for the first time nice welcome
welcome
all right here we go I'm gonna go and
switch over guys
we definitely do not want to miss
anything and for some reason it's not
letting us go full screen yet so
hopefully once it starts we'll get to uh
so the fact that they're like labeling
this is gameplay showcase 2. I feel like
that means pretty good odds there is a
third one
I feel like that but who knows right I
mean I feel like January would be a good
time for it
because they did one
let's see was James's was it November
and then yeah November so then now
December and then January like the build
up right to the launch in in February
that would be good timing
CJ how's it going welcome CJ
Stephen first time
uh first time cart
first time chat maybe maybe first time
chat
six minutes I know let's go let's go
so yeah you should still uh if you
become a member of Super Chat you'll see
it down there at the bottom in the
scroll but it just won't pop up and go
crazy
all right four minutes you guys four
minutes
and
I'm gonna make sure I turn off the music
too I feel like we're about to watch a
movie I know dude I know and see I'm so
mad because I didn't get to do this for
the uh when James had his showcase I
didn't get to do this because we had our
biggest like work training day of the
year was that day and they told us like
the day before so there was no no time
to prepare I couldn't have got out of
that one anyway
but um this one I'm actually on I'm on
my break at work right now I'm on lunch
break I was like okay I gotta get
started early with work
I don't have it didn't have any meetings
scheduled for today so it's like I can I
can time it just right so I take my
lunch
right when the Showcase is about to
start
um and you know we'll go for a little
bit after and then of course we will uh
man we'll have multiple videos coming
out and then a full live stream
breakdown next week so for those of you
who maybe don't get to it uh check out
all of our streams we do stream
regularly right here on YouTube
usually 8 P.M eastern time on Tuesday
evenings is usually when we do Noob with
a super chat
need Noob I can still see the super
chats even if they don't pop up and go
crazy Noob says uh retro get your
hydration also you should show your RAR
moment to the gym oh yeah Noob has a
great clip when Noob started this whole
RAR thing r-a-w-r on stream
and Noob very quickly uh made sure to
clip that one
made sure to clip that one and we do
have some hydration here Cherry Coke
Zero our drink of choice for today
even got snacks too
I'm almost out but these little uh
Trader Joe's dark chocolate almonds
so good
so good
we've got just a couple left though I'm
probably not gonna be eating a lot once
once the stream starts anyway all right
two minutes let's go
I'm gonna go ahead and um turn off the
Spotify
just because we'll want to have make
sure this is at full volume once once we
go here
head coach today regular Coke yeah I'm a
I'm a Coke Zero guy I I stopped drinking
um
regular sodas I don't know about a year
or so ago
I gained I was I mean I've always been
on the you know smaller side never been
a heavy person but during the pandemic I
definitely put on a little bit of weight
was the heaviest I'd ever been I was
like okay
I can't
um I can't handle this so stop drinking
sodas and man during the pandemic it was
just such a weird time like me and my
kid my kids love ice cream I love ice
cream there was a time when we would
just have ice cream like every night I
was like okay we gotta stop we gotta
stop this
we gotta stop the every night thing
we're just making ice cream sundaes so
yeah then as when I cut out that well I
still eat ice cream but just like you
know once twice a week
and then I cut out all regular sodas too
but yeah hydration at the ready kangor
don't know a single person who didn't
gained some I heard of some people
actually lost weight you know like from
stress levels but yeah I mean for me we
were just like
I just we just want to make it fun for
the kids you know like try to make this
a time that they don't look back on when
they're older like oh that was such a
scary time
and you know for a lot of us it was
there was so much uncertainty especially
early all right it says 60 Seconds
and it should be okay Premiere will
begin shortly let's go
as soon as it goes up I will um
actually Let me refresh here let me
refresh
because it needs to let us take this to
uh
full screen
all right my clock still says 12 59 so
as soon as it changed over to one I'm
gonna refresh it again
Dominic I'm in class but present let's
go
give us a gameplay Avada Kedavra I think
they're gonna I think we're gonna get
both today
I think we're gonna get both
Gabriella yo thank you for the Super
Chat Gabriella
first time being on a live stream hello
and thank you
thank you for being here and thank you
for showing support
with the Super Chat
oh come on
come on
where is it
all right my clock's showing one my
clock's showing one
let's go dude
come on Chandler push the button
push the button
does Chandler have to like push the
button or something to activate this oh
wait
[Music]
guys we already
we already did the countdown
we are
oh this is this what happened with the
last one
see I didn't get to live stream it I
didn't even get to watch it live so I
don't know did they do the same thing
there
the bait
oh
we were baited
that disappointment
see Chandler I mean you gotta you gotta
start the five minute countdown
you gotta set it to go up at 11 50 or
what uh 12.55
see I've I've had to learn this the hard
way because if I tell people I'm going
live at eight
then it's like okay do we start do I go
live at 7 50 and have the 10 minute
countdown
oh man it's all good
they did the same oh gotcha gotcha
okay I appreciate the chat not one of
you telling me none of you deciding to
we're just gonna let him find out
come on man
now in all seriousness I did see a note
from Chandler so the live stream is not
available in 4k
however
I I guess as soon as this ends they will
be posting the um the 4K version
so if it looks a little blurry on your
screen here I mean 1080 should still be
should still be really good quality but
um the 4K one will be obviously much
better that's that's the one you want to
look at when you when you go back
and you want to look for all the little
secrets and details which you know we
got to do another one of those now
um you definitely want to make sure
you're looking at that 4K version for
sure
took like 15 minutes gotcha okay
how live streams work streamer stays
Clues and learn the hard way
oh see I wish I'd gotten to do the first
one I would have known
I would have known that
uh Zero's wolf of death hey thank you
for the Super Chat there retro you're a
great streamer can't wait to see
Hogwarts Legacy and be a dark wizard
hope you and Andy reloads get to talk
together more yeah I hope so too I'm
gonna try to be on um
Alex at podcast now is having a big big
big stream on Friday
with I mean basically almost all of the
Hogwarts Legacy creators except wife
wants a wizard which I know he has tried
to get wife once a wizard everybody
always is like come on what about wife
wants a wizard I know Alex has tried for
sure to get wife once wizard
but um I think wife wants a wizard
prefers to you know kind of maintain his
presence in the shadows if you will
but yeah I don't know if I'll be able to
join for the whole thing
um but I will I am planning to be on
that one at some point it'll probably be
more toward the end
of that of that stream
all right I'm gonna tilt my microwave
while I chew this very loud almond and
we're gonna hydrate again
[Music]
and in addition it looks like we had um
uh Rossi with a super chat
right right there as well what type of
content we make after Hogwarts legacies
out yeah we were talking about this on
last night's live stream so
I mean I'll definitely keep doing
Hogwarts stuff for a while
especially if they do any kind of DLC or
anything like that but I'm expecting to
do more gameplay live streams
our Tuesday live streams will probably
shift into more of just like a general
gaming news I don't know we'll see like
because that show our our Tuesday live
stream is so much about chat and the
directions that they take us I usually
go in with a loose plan
but yeah I mean I'm thinking current
topics in gaming maybe things in the
Wizarding World if we can ever get Harry
Potter magic awakened to come out in the
U.S
and I do have some ideas for some videos
I'm actually already working on
some video ideas now that will obviously
we can always cover gaming news that'll
be you know I can I can look at what
games I'm I'm hyped for things like
Zelda things like
um star field
Final Fantasy I mean all all the big
games I can look at doing those maybe
more like uh you guys mentioned Andy
reloads more covering variety games like
Andy does
but with my name being retro reckon tour
as we have 20 seconds here to go oh no
don't do me like that don't scare me I
was like wait is it my stream or is it
their stream
um but with my name being retro racket
tour we talk about lots of things with
stories and video games I have some
ideas for story as well
and how uh
how stories and games kind of impact us
impact our lives so stay tuned for that
here we go
all right rated T for teen
all right is that too loud is that just
right
on their sound we want to make sure we
can hear it
just give me a thumbs up if the sound is
good
[Music]
all right most people saying just right
just right
I'm gonna put it back up just a bit then
back to where I had it
all right most people saying thumbs up
are let's good
[Music]
hey everybody Welcome to the Hogwarts
what up Chandler play showcase I'm
Chandler Wood Community manager here at
Avalanche software and I'm honored to
introduce you to our panel today first
up we have Community guest host Ben snow
oh my God I can't believe this is
happening thank you so much for having
me and from the Avalanche team we have
game director Alan two hello everybody
and assistant Alan with the hands hi and
finally just off-screen capturing
gameplay for us Andrew Coram Andrew
again there he is there he is today
we'll be giving you a taste of the open
world via broom flight a deeper look at
combat using the dark arts battle arena
and a look at your personalizable home
within Hogwarts the room of requirement
where we may even see some beasts
so dark arts battle is starting driver
left off in our last gameplay showcase
just outside Hogwarts which I love that
we can you can walk out of the castle
after walking through everything and
then just come out here and take off on
your broom out into the open world oh my
goodness Alan I know that's something
that you particularly incendio icon on
the right over there pretty sure that's
incendio I'm a big fan of just being
able to hop on the broom and go anywhere
there's something about kind of like the
the sensation of of everything being
open to you and just oh let's go dude I
can get to things I love flying close to
the ground and and I I kind of wanted to
talk about it just because I feel like
um you know the brooms are fun for me
not just because I heard somebody
talking they flew by inspiration but but
because they're not just I have a broom
and it's done I actually kind of like
some of the mechanics in it so you can
oh my gosh you see all these little
things popping up meter there and
occasionally as Andrew's kind of flying
up or flying down you might notice it in
draining or not and and this isn't the
present day where all the technology is
well known and advanced and and
everything that we know and love this is
an earlier time where they're still
trying to figure out you know we're not
at the 3000 yet we're at the 11. so I
just I'm just so speechless right now
because this is just so beautiful sorry
Macy I was trying but it's uh another
language is that like the only one or
can you here we go
yeah so we have uh good question Ben
to us that the player could customize
themselves based on their own Aesthetics
so they're purely cosmetic but uh purely
cosmetic okay shopkeep and help him out
he'll actually sell upgrades
yeah and those those upgrades will nice
where normally the broom you can only
fly
um you can only go at Max Speed it's
kind of like a turbo meter down there
you can only go it yeah without the
meter going down kind of closer to the
ground and as you raise into the air
you'll notice the meter drop and so
those upgrades will allow you to
increase that distance from the ground
and there the the broom owner at at the
sporting goods store in in hogsmead is
trying to perfect the broom and get
better oh I love it and know it better
and you can participate that and get
better and better brooms through this I
see and I love that that mechanic
encourages you to actually explore the
world and kind of stay close to the
ground it's not just a travel mechanic
point A to point B you're not just
flying high over everything although it
is beautiful
as well there's lots to lots to explore
on the ground and so kind of keeping you
down at the ground to me it feels like
it's got this kind of Surfing Vibe over
the over the like I'm just like I want
to snatch the controller from Andrew
right now because I want to go to the
Mountaintop I'm going to the forest
enter that Hamlet
and so uh we all know for more that
hogsmeade is the only all Wizarding
village within Britain oh
slick meet other characters out here and
to kind of populate the landscape so
it's not just kind of you know Barren as
you leave out this direction dude so we
just imagine these different dwellings
these different smaller locations that
that Wizards might live so much to break
down right Scottish highlights right and
so it's a cute little tip and so we
refer to those as hamlets and their
opportunities to learn those wizard
stories
um how those different locations have
kind of like learned to live what their
relationships are with characters that
Hogs me from Hogwarts and so they're
both Quest opportunities out here and a
chance to kind of get to know more of
the area even Beyond Hogwarts and
hogsmead that we've already experienced
and you'll also notice on the mini map
like lots of little icons and each one
of those represents the kid over there
pretending to write a broom I think
participate in you know whether it's a
vendor or different puzzles and
challenges or different secrets that
exist
um each one of those icons are different
opportunities for gameplay and you'll
notice that that same thing as we
venture out into the open world as well
so when you go out into the open world
and you see see those icons whether
they're on the mini map or on your map
or off all the icons so many breakdowns
capacity there are puzzles left behind
by old Wizards you know that you can
solve that actually come on drop the
name drop the name ruins off in the off
in the distance and you visit them
it's Merlin and learn about your ancient
magic and as you and as you kind of
encounter different enemies dotted on
the landscape sometimes those characters
poachers or dark Wizards might be
hoarding different uh magical resources
that are valuable to you have a little
butter beer so each one has kind of like
a way to connect to our gameplay loops
and provide different opportunities that
just kind of reward you for post oh I
didn't see a sitting
but there is something that we haven't
done so far and that is uh oh my gosh
yes
um we're gonna hop on our honestly let's
go dude Sonic's hippogriff is our
pre-order bonus oh
my god of course yeah um the animation
on that ground Mount and you can lift
off into the air and we tried to make
sure that each each of those so the
broom's really good at reaching that top
speed at that kind of traveling the
world as quickly as possible but
sometimes it's really nice to get on the
hippogriff because of that ground speed
uh or those trans
and sometimes it just feels amazing just
to be writing oh yeah always Alan always
yeah it's it really is kind of like uh I
don't know it's a great feeling being on
it and it's great feeling managing those
transitions kind of going from run to
fly so you can't just run around on the
ground
that each one of these things that you
can interact with so interesting
identity and a reason for being
and oh my God like I see like different
like two wheel information by the way
can you go to like entire map anywhere
you go there are regions that are like
locked from you yeah as soon as as soon
as you there's kind of a moment where
the world kind of opens up to you
outside okay Hogwarts as a student and
right from that moment early on in the
game you can go wherever you want no way
my more difficult challenges in
different areas no way responses
Andrew's moving around like you
mentioned swamp
um but there was hoping that was how
it'd be coast and we've got different
types of environments out in the world
just to kind of uh pepper your
experiences which is fresh uh all those
things exist
I love that windmill it's like so rustic
like I keep forgetting that this is like
1800s the wizard in the world would
never really sing before like it feels
so right right like it just it's part of
it yeah I love this Vista too and I
can't wait to see this in 4k man stop
here we're gonna use a bit of Dev magic
to uh change the seasons actually I want
to see I want you to see what this world
looks like yes Winter Please winter yes
yes yes ladies for Ben snow right
[Music]
entering Dev commands
we gotta I mean you gotta show a snow
landscape with our boy Ben snow here
dude look at it
this is so pretty okay you can kind of
just like hover there in the air with
the uh landscape like completely did you
guys catch that like the hippogriffy
kind of just hover with it for a bit
cool like gameplay impact like an impact
on the gameplay or just like it's just
the weather of Scotland uh yeah we use
it we really use it as a narrative
marker through through the game so
similar to that what the movies did
important for us to kind of like have
those moments that kind of take my money
when you're reading the books or
watching the movies where Galaxy
and now the landscape has changed and
you're really feeling those that passage
of time while you're a student you know
going through it's gorgeous and this
isn't even the 4K version I mean anybody
wanted to duplicate that they upload
this in 4k on the outside which which I
I agree I think it's really beautiful
um but within the school as well so
there are moments like when it reaches
certain holidays or things like that
where hogsmead
holidays oh yeah
that really helped just kind of make me
feel like I'm there you just confirmed
it let's go and it's not just uh it's
not just I mean it had to be there right
it had to be there those kind of vibe
things
um like we have a day night cycle and
that day night cycle it even though
similarly like it's largely about Vibe
when you go into hogsmeade in the
evening there's less characters there
around the school you'll notice it kind
of dies down and quiets down just I mean
there's just Candlelight and students
kind of like right because some of them
a lot of them go home in that daylight
cycle is where we've kind of placed a
few items where you know whether or not
you can collect them or whether or not
you can interact with them that are a
little bit restricted by the day night
cycle nice and I love Andrews flying up
here really high up on the hippogriff
and and we're just looking at this view
of Hogwarts in the distance it's just
absolutely beautiful dude what I love
most about flying around this is you
like this is really big
you know I I mean you talk about this is
really big see in the distance and
that's one of my I I still can't get
over like no matter I played like that
question mark right there over the fact
that I can see Hogwarts out there like
what is there not knowing that all of
all of the things inside of it the
classrooms the students the professors
um all the places I can go I can just
fly my hippogriff land in the courtyard
enter the front doors and just walk you
know to the Walmart gosh dude to my
common room that it's all contiguous get
right one question marks on those
creatures
magical creatures right they look like
wolves or something right now are just
absolutely beautiful interrupt a
charging Mongrel with the pulsive a lot
more time out here see these little
Feats that keep popping out Merlin
puzzle maybe right there sorry this is a
great opportunity to switch over to
trying to like balance how much I'm
talking kind of an intro to combat this
time excitement to go down right now a
lot more of a deep dive so we can hear
what they're saying using the dark arts
battle arena which is part of our combat
deep dive let's go let's go right
Andrew's got us in the Forbidden Forest
which is where the dark arts battle
arena is which is part of the deluxe and
digital deluxe edition I I love the way
that the dark arts battle arena is
actually uh part of the world it's
integrated into the world so your
experience is more immersive than just
choosing an option from from the main
menu of the game or something like that
exactly there are many reasons to go to
the Forbidden Forest but he's also
wearing the uh dark arts cosmetic set
and uh here he's pulling out the
thestral which is oh my God part of that
dark ice pack from the deluxe and
digital deluxe edition so we're going
full full dark whoever had the idea of
doing that
that little pack put on the animation
battle arena it is a great brilliant
give that person a raise really combat
in a big way because it unlocks some
interesting abilities for you and and
allows you to to really play around with
the little uh little toads toys and is
this like the only Arena like this in
the game where you can like practice it
yeah so in the in the base game we have
two combat Arenas no normally that and
so everyone has access to those and each
of the combator units are an opportunity
to kind of just go through a difficult
combat challenge what in order to earn a
a different cosmetic for your character
and add that oh that's cool in the case
of the that's no different than the dark
arts battle arena that's also waves of
enemies the combat Arena but it's uh
unforgivable curse so one of the things
that we're excited about confirmed is
the is the other icon that we've been
kind of pre-loaded with different
abilities so uh the unforgivable curses
are something that everyone's going to
have access to interesting oh come on
Andrew I'm blurring out the Spells
repertoire and they can also commit to
that balance that's too funny talents
and things like that when you when you
play the Dark Horse combat Arena you
actually have access to all those things
as kind of like a way to test them all
and so it's a chance to kind of like
tour and play with the dark arts and
decide whether or not that is a path I
keep wanting to pause
um but but yeah everyone has the same
ability to explore explore the dark arts
this is just kind of like a way of
playing that's cool so for those of us
who want to be purely good no dark arts
in general we can still get a little
taste jump in here and still get a
little taste of it you know start
battling and we can start talking about
dude the animation on them dropping in
that's not stupefied right away
we're starting off strong oh my God
oh my God that's so cool yeah so that
you'll you'll notice right away like
when we use Avada Kedavra that guy's how
far went from instant to zero and we
really are trying oh my gosh on her the
way Avada cadaver works in the game even
in some pretty extreme situations
um you guys like the the meter takes up
a lot longer to yeah build up as a way
to kind of deal with its extreme power
just understandable fun to use and then
there's some some ways that we'll
probably talk about not a finisher
though to adjust that but I don't know
not a finisher's on the screen that you
just have questions about well like I
see like little blue these
from the enemies also we put like that
sign well it's like so in the commuter
we call it the ancient magic sign I
don't know if that's how it's cold yeah
in the game
it's a magic symbol on the development
side and in player facing in the game we
referenced
so as your as your abilities in the game
keep growing and you become exposed to
some of the secrets dude there's so much
so much the process here abilities
um you start unlocking new powers so one
of those Powers you'll see the R1 button
appearance
an ancient magic all three of them kind
of like draw an object to you and swing
it at an enemy
um okay but whenever you see the R1 or
the L1 plus R1 up here over somebody's
head so that's an ability to count
bottom right guys bottom right notice
the d-pad popping up that's how they're
switching between the Spells there's a
ton of damage against the characters and
the way that manifests itself uh we need
to listen to Allen I'll be quiet and
you'll see a wide variety of enemies in
here that are pressuring the player in
different ways you'll notice there's
there's uh abilities that kind of bubble
up under the player as it's fighting
that force them to move and there's
different ways that we want the player
to kind of move around just torturing
them right there that's actually a good
link to the internet here in general the
reason why I say that is because as
you're doing different things in combat
you're portuguing and you're doing
different abilities and you can kind of
spectrum through with your talents there
are different ways to get that meter to
build faster and faster so one of the
most effective base ways to build up
that meter fast that way you can launch
these devastating attacks whenever you
want to is is to actually perform
confidence
it's almost like your your emotions are
building up and then basically that
builds up enough that you can attack
someone but as the combo meter builds up
at some point dude these Goblin attacks
and a piece of their magic kind of falls
out of them you'll see these blue orbs
in in the in the game world and there's
something that only you can see in in
the narrative in the world and it's
another reason to move around on the
battlefield if you can go up and collect
those things and put them in right Nico
the sound effect on crucio
talking a lot about about spells and
Magic here but I think there's another
huge component of combat and that is
that you can bring to combat as well to
kind of uh change the way you play and I
think Mackenzie knows a lot about l r
when it's the uh the tools are really
interesting because they're basically
like a prior investment so you can bring
the potions and the plants that you grow
in the room of requirement to combat to
essentially kind of help you
um defeat enemies a lot quicker and more
efficiently so some of the tools that
you'll see here are like the rock Skin
Potion so that is something that
basically covers your skin there's been
so much time here perfecting that
reduces the incoming damage control so
against big enemies hard-hitting enemies
like trolls
um that's super oh two of them
him out uh obviously we have the Wicked
Wheel potion as well uh which increases
your health and then we have the focus
potion so when Alan talks about oh my
gosh having to balance the vodaca.com
is brew a focus potion and that will
increase
um how quickly your your cooldowns uh
regain right
right now like he's just bouncing around
around and then you can then you've
built up AK and you can akm again move
around
oh my goodness I love that our plants
are violent yes and so that's like when
we're talking about the plants almost
the setup of the Arena you also have
plants and so we have things like the
venomous stuff you get an armored troll
down and it acts like a turret and it
just kind of shoots enemies around the
battlefield that is so cool this is like
a truly like hufflepuffian way to
approach the battle exactly no that was
super important to us so there were
these like multiple ways and so you can
see there's there's a ton of different
things you can use uh the Mandrake is
one so you can pull it out right
piercing cries enemies I'm gonna have to
re-watch this so many times another
thing I want to call out uh that we're
seeing on the side of the screen here is
these these dueling Feats which I love
because I love anything that prompts me
to play a game in a different way a
unique way I don't want to get stuck in
my style you know yeah that's a good
question Luna so this is a way to it was
a one shot for the troll yes if you just
want to blast people with spells go for
it but we also even the one with full
health uh have some things over here I
think you use certain plants or certain
potions or block more or some of the
random objects you could use
um uh in the fire stream and the field
guide challenge is this is the way the
field guide manifests like challenges
for you to do
and exactly to your point um I'm just
trying to figure out how much damage
crucio is doing to explore the different
systems he's definitely stunned over
there the guy in the red over there he's
just like explore what they want to do
because there really are so many
different ways there we go we gotta look
at it right there when you see the the
green x's on characters that's right and
that's kind of uh through your talents
you can unlock this kind of cursing
mechanic that sort of like links the
fates of these different characters on
the battlefield what uh as you get the
as you're cursing different characters
they all begin sharing damage and so oh
that's right things like about a cadaver
which is the insta kill but if you curse
everyone before you instant kill this
one guy they can all drop dead for that
kind of ultimate oh that is sick oh my
god there are there are dark arts
fantasies there's fantasies about being
more of a defense against the dark arts
character things like that that Misty
step that you see um occasionally being
used on the battlefield and we can also
spec into our potions and plants yeah
show us the the defense against the dark
darts Alan it's all about which type of
player you feel like you're are and
whether or not you want to play with
practice oh he just did oh Imperial like
he's just attacked him and those are all
that is so cool forgot about it period
like I see so much like going on on this
into so much complexity and I I want to
just try it myself like which style
works best I mean I feel like it's the
Dark Horse it's gonna be amazing
magic to be honest feels like much more
powerful than just the dark Hearts yeah
and speaking of plants and Potions we
are going to be putting the dark arts
away put those unforgivables they cut
off Allen right there we're heading to
the room of requirement I wanted to see
what he said about the uh Hogwarts a
personalizable space
utility as well where you get to brew
things and grow things and uh uh also
care for some beasts
right Andrew's got us in the room that
was so good that was so good we kind of
went casual mode on the outfit here
wearing a nice job so here are the icons
in the bottom right that we were
breaking down on the stream last night
trying to figure out what each of those
mean
for uh the personalization of the space
see what you did there see what you did
character and the visuals of your
character but actually the space is a
place that you can make your own
um yeah it was super important to us
that this space really did feel like
um your reflection uh as a wizard so you
can change the architecture in here
what
beautiful we never expected that to be
oh my God it bins exactly not only can
you change the architecture here but you
can actually conjure things that we just
didn't even anticipate you can see so
except for the bedside tables there's
like statues that you can do and
ornaments and tables and rugs and just a
bunch of little things we're playing The
Sims is this Animal Crossing oh my
goodness because like we we had an idea
that those places where you brew stuff
that's where you can change but you can
do a whole of this where do you even get
this stuff like there's a furniture
store
yeah so we call them conjurations uh and
the conjuration recipes conjuration
recipes Frozen Hogs made
um also as you engage in different types
of gameplay throughout the world you'll
be rewarded with uh different objects
that's so cool and you change color you
can change the color you can change the
size of it and you can place it
basically anywhere
it's like a baby niffler your little
household friends the system too is
designed it's not mechanical what and so
you get the magic effective contract are
you kidding me right now you're actually
doing this in the world yeah people are
gonna spend so much time just in here
and I love the animation how it like
appears you know like it's not just like
there it's like it almost like it
operates it is really quite beautiful
and that was the thing is we wanted that
looks really nice because the Magic in
The Wizarding World is everywhere
we really wanted to nail that Whimsy in
this space but another thing that I
wanted to discuss is that that animation
dude I conjure things and you can change
their their look but you can do that
with the utility objects I have so many
thoughts but I'm trying to listen to and
potion stations and you can change the
look of this as well and these are the
areas where as we had mentioned
previously you'll be growing your plants
you'll be brewing your posts I had a
feeling I had a feeling this whole room
is required
like kind of nurturing surprise to a lot
of people also the space where you would
bring your gear Gear to be identified
and geared to have um this is insane
dude this is insanely Alan can talk oh
yeah um we keep bringing up a little
hopping pot over there how it looks and
and on like uh in the game you can look
like anything you want to whenever you
want to
um but the player will be finding
different types of gear that we call it
uh as you progress through the game and
essentially we just know that that
clothes and different items we gotta go
back and read that to technical
properties and as you uh as you explore
and as You Adventure as you defeat
enemies you're going to be finding
different pieces of gear that have
different abilities and that can help
you there was blue purple and growing as
a wizard and advancing as a wizard and
so there's a huge list and not all the
time my goodness we never whenever you
get a new piece of gear you don't
necessarily know exactly what it does
and so there's a station inside of the
room of requirement that you can
Congress versus tingling called stats
that that care that you're uncertain
about and learn what its abilities are
right yeah that's so cool and then as
the space advances even further and the
space will eventually grow its own rooms
the rose wolf of death
all these different things keep
expanding and as it expands eventually
you're going to earn what we see here
which is called the loom and when you
set up a loom it's an ability to
essentially it's called extraordinary
which magical properties are on your
gear and take any piece of gear and
adjust it goodness
and I mentioned earlier that that you
can make anything look like anything the
collection of of cus uh of
um appearances we call it or um
Cosmetics we've been lost for words
right stream those types of things you
can use and you can apply a look to any
other other look so if you get a piece
of gear you put it on
to look like whatever you want nice
that's so cool and like you just you can
just put some ability to this sweater
but then you can just swap yeah ability
yep and the appearances you can edit
whenever you want in the gear screen the
loom is specifically about applying uh
traits and and applying uh larger
upgrades that just kind of grant you
greater statistics
abilities blend in nicely with where
you're trying to go with your combat
fantasy decrease damage taken from
spiders from inferior I'm just like I'm
just saying that they're just like
pumpkin fur mooncuffer where does that
come from yeah and so you'll notice that
the ingredients that are used to add
traits and to upgrade your gear are
based around beasts so this is where we
get into the Beast care section which is
inside oh my gosh here we go on a bigger
space on the inside idea and so you can
see here we have a couple of beasts and
a moon calf and a niffler uh and a knees
up close it's just like a big puppy so
they're cuddling oh my God together oh
that's so cute they're adorable and so
part of Beast care is petting them as
well but feeding them there you go you
do those things
they'll give you their their magical fur
Etc uh that can then be used in your in
your gear that is like so like intuitive
because like you know that makes sense
because when you touch the animals you
get some fur leftovers that's so
my God yeah and we really want to hammer
home the fact that this is like a home
that you're making for them so in the
Overland you can find these Beast ends
and rescue these beasts part of doing so
is brushing them and feeding them they
cut something she said right there to
build that relationship with with your
beef in addition to be able to care for
beasts you can actually oh I can't wait
to watch this 4K as well uh the cottage
yes right and so we have like a lot of
little diesel right there in this area
and a lot of them are purely cosmetic
but they look really cool again it's the
personalization of this space oh that's
so fun good there's no this is like
that's so fun eight hours just designing
this whole dude people are gonna spend
so much time just inside these things
like you've got room of requirements and
then within the room of requirement just
there's multiple bavariums I'm pretty
sure there's multiple ones and there's
like a decoration aspect but there's
also we were saying inside uh as well is
there's a utility utility aspect to it
too so as you progress in the game and
you're able to purchase more
conjurations you're able to speed up
your process so one of them for example
is the food processor which allows dude
it's like a care of magical creatures
Sim within Hogwarts Legacy uh uh you're
really
building the progression for yourself
in addition there's a
dog box where you can play with your
beasts
super cute
oh my God watching them oh there he
comes there he comes
there you go the world is a dangerous
place and so by going and rescuing these
beasts and bringing them back here and
caring for them you're really helping
helping them out there's poachers in the
Overland uh who want to who hunt these
Beasts for their material so instead
you're caring for them you're giving
them a home
yeah I know it's huge right but it's way
bigger than the ones we've seen so far
oh you could actually name them as well
these magical materials you can name
them getting back into that
personalization they confirmed it we
didn't want you to just like we were
asking about this last night on stream
you're like oh it can be yes whatever
Andrew's about to name them let's see
Bruce
hello Bruce uh you know we 've we've
created this really
really and and uh you can get additional
vivariums correct uh it's a different
kind of
Aesthetics there we go I knew it had to
be more than one
yeah your beast and caring for them
percussion is a big part of the space as
well so as you progress through the
story
customizable so as you can see this
one's quite Meadow themed
um big open bright uh but there's other
ones say like a swamp that you might
encounter and it's really a visual
effect to uh and more space for for your
large tree oh so it's like those when
we're inside the room requirement
there's like right right there's that
moon glow from One Tree is well on its
way to becoming a grand old oak
oh you put trees in here too oh my
goodness
and another thing with the the business
losing his mind uh as we are now the
same kind of thing that you did with
like the broom where the broom is not
just a method of travel Pokemon Harry
Potter integrated into the world in the
same way like Beast care isn't just this
this I told you guys like throwing it on
top there's really this like narrative
yes integration too they didn't include
a lot of little mini games but this this
kind of stuff right here makes up for
that I feel like
um as you earn resources you'll go into
hogsmeade and and use them to uh
in the open world uh it's in those
different
um in those different environments like
the different combat and conflicts and
bandicamps and different things like
that that exist in the Overland those
things are what hold recipes uh that
exist in the loom oh my goodness I love
that these things have a way of
connecting
um Moonstone that you find out in the
world is the research how big is this
space like where obviously there are
physical limitations at some point so
really like how how big can you make
this area it keeps you coming back but
even with the story that's being told
too you know I think people know who
poppy is and and uh that she hasn't no
who is she yeah I mean I think
everything we're seeing here you know
you're going to be venturing out into
the world uh and and this is just kind
of the tip of the iceberg even even
though it's kind of like you're
interacting excuse me so you know you're
bringing up you said this is the tip of
the iceberg there are more uh kind of
mysteries to discover and things to
discover around the world that have to
do with her and that have to do with
caring for beasts and so different
characters
I told you that that just kind of make
this all just kind of the beginning the
beginning of your journey
well we could spend hours in here but
yes we could let's stream now let's just
go ahead about what you've seen today
this is I'm just so blown away by how
how beautiful it looks the open world
seems so detailed and there's so many
things to do and like the combat we're
gonna have we're gonna spend like two
weeks or more just breaking it down by
pieces there's just so much
to this world like I'm so happy you guys
know it's been it's like I I don't know
what to say the tip of the iceberg we've
got more for you to discover and find on
your own oh wait oh you know so much for
being here we're gonna be busy for
watching Hogwarts Legacy is available
for free we're gonna be busy release is
February 10th with 72-hour Early Access
for owners of the collectors Deluxe and
digital deluxe edition we're gonna wrap
things up but not on the last 10 guys
bye little surprise oh
another preview of what's to come
all right we got a Slither in here
use
okay wait
[Music]
wait what
wait what
what was that all about okay hold on we
can rewind it now okay
oh my goodness okay hold on so where
where are these this is Slytherin common
room or is this the library
okay they walk up to a book here
it says use
then we get like this little cut scene
the book
what is happening here
oh dude we can get it there was there
was a brief
that looks like the book
um
oh the with I mean with Merlin and
Morgana and all that that that James has
been talking about
and then the character just gets sucked
up into the book
[Music]
what in the world
portkey oh my goodness okay
wow
wow
I mean
what do you guys think
10 out of 10 dude I'm like okay gifted
10 members Martin gifted tennis
memberships
I got a comment here
what in the world oh all right I gotta
let's see what James is saying dude
he's probably not gonna see my comment
Professor Drew Drew
well God is horror
crud was that morgana's horcrux it did
is it I was I was kind of getting like
Tom Riddle Vibes like Tom Riddle diary
Vibes you know version it
he's looking for the 4K too that's what
I was about to check
I'm just going to go back that's
oh
oh man that's what we just did dude
man I'll have to catch up with James
later that's too good
all right let's see if they got the 4K
4K is up 4K is up you guys
all right 4K version is up
actually before I do that though hold on
let me turn my alerts back on you guys I
see it I see at least you're not with
the ten dollar Super Chat Leisure not
thank you so much for your support and
the Super Chat I mean I feel like that
was 10 out of 10 guys like 10 out of 10.
showing
that was just way more than I expected
I mean even though they only cut they
covered what they said they were going
to be covering and yet somehow it was
wow wow all right let me uh refresh this
hit save right here
and then we're going to turn the
all right let me uh I'm gonna have to
leave this screen for a second
and then we'll come back in and it
should refresh all of that
all right there we go chats rolling
and we've got the names going at the
bottom I can't I can't even word
right
okay
where do we even begin dude
where do we even begin
Peyton thank you so much for renewing
your membership and also Leisure knot
with the 10 super chat Noob with another
Super Chat we got kidnapped by a book
and the curses look at sound beautiful
thank you for the Super Chat Noob Dylan
with the Super Chat back to work for me
had fun I'm so excited 54 days
Dylan dude I'm glad you're able to be
here man I am just I am blown away as
well you guys I am uh okay
first off
first off I don't even know where to
begin how about that for a first off
okay let's talk about
I feel like the part that I was most
curious about
this right here man let's this is what
everybody will want to see
is the AK
is the AK that's what everybody's will
want to see uh Elwyn with the Super Chat
had tears when we got to I knew you
would love that part L one I knew it
I mean they confirm we can name them
they confirm that we can uh we didn't
get any confirmation on breeding again
guys uh we try to keep things spoiler
free so if you can don't mention the
trophies but we've seen we could you
know what they showed there we do see
like the male female icons that were at
the top as they were interacting with
each Beast so it would lead you to
believe there is some sort of you know
there's a reason for that right so is
there going to be some type of breeding
we saw we've seen babies maybe maybe we
will see all right
so I want to go back to this like right
when they get into the uh
and each of the combat Arenas oh my gosh
it looks so much better in the 4K
version
oh
all right let's go on inside here all
right I want to get it back to where
they use AK right right at the jump
explore the dark arts this is just kind
of like a way of creating Noob with
another Super Chat we saw it there's a
breeding pin did they actually show it
did they show a breeding pin Jump In
Here Andrew well there you go
start battling and let's go
all right
I mean
dude they know what the audience wants
let me tell you that
we're just talking about we got a human
a human character right here ashwinder
Scout level 18.
and uh yeah I mean if you were wondering
about can we AK humans because we only
saw it on the um we saw it on the gobble
in the very first time and then we saw
it in the uh on the troll right here at
the jump it's this little unsuspecting
boom ache
right away oh my God crucio
okay now this is what oh see this is oh
this one we get to get to start breaking
it down Blue Moon renewing their
subscription as well Blue Moon thank you
so much
welcome uh as you continue to be a
member of House wreck and tour here
Payton hey Peyton thank you for
subscribing to the channel
thank you for subscribing to the channel
all right I'm so glad to share this
moment with all of you Wolfie right that
was just epic that was epic
the green X giving me Riddler vibes from
Batman that's exactly what I was going
to talk about so this is what they were
saying about the the curses remember
when they revealed imperio and it had it
had that information about uh giving
them the cursed effect or whatever so
they said that is what this x means so
let's talk about crucio here
I mean avad kadava crazy but then I'm
gonna turn volume all the way up here
listen to this sound I saw Nico
commenting on it during the live stream
listen to this after they cast Cruces oh
my God
we're starting off strong oh my God
you're like those like just terrified
Whispers it's like
oh it's so creepy
you guys are gonna love it we're
starting off strong oh my God okay so it
doesn't do a lot of damage look at that
this is crucio so AK obviously
immediately depletes the meter Allen
talked about how they wanted to make
sure that was true to the book so even
on the the troll that had the huge
amount of XP uh there was a lot of us
wondering like how is that going to work
you know how are they going to balance
that AK just like the book it's instant
fully depleted whether you're a mountain
troll human Goblin whatever and that's
what we just saw that saw there now
crucio on the other hand let's take a
look here oh my God
see crucio did looks like 41 damage
however it gives them the cursed status
effect right here now let's see if it
keeps ticking
it does okay yeah we saw it we saw just
a glimpse of it so crucial is Gonna Keep
ticking down we're starting off strong
watch it right there
so it drops down again so crucio that's
going to be like a damage over time
thing looks like it ticks for 48 right
there now imperio is another spell that
we know can also apply this curse status
effect
so what they were saying and they were
talking about dark fantasies who knows
how many spells are going to have this
capability right
we know for sure crucio now because we
see it right here we know for sure
imperio are there going to be any others
that have this that can apply this
cursed effect here because theoretically
what you could have depending on however
many spells and how fast your meter can
refill I mean what they were saying
that Dark Fantasy Power Trip is you
could curse like five or six enemies
right and then they start to share
damage
they share damage and then once you have
all these enemies sharing damage curse
another one and then cast AK on it and
they all drop at the same time
they all drop at the same time that is
insane
so see you start getting that little X
effect right there and then they cast
imperio so imperio on that one note the
change in the eyes right there we see
the eyes change to get kind of this blue
and also this sort of I don't know
greenish smoke but also the little green
X to denote that hey they are currently
cursed so this enemy here
and then the one we just saw before that
they are they are now sharing damage
not yet not yet but right now now
they're sharing damage
oh dude you hear the guy screaming too
you hear the guy screaming over on the
right
oh my goodness
you hear him screaming James thinks the
book we got is the collector's edition
oh could be could be right away like
when we use Avada Kedavra that guy's how
far went from instant to zero and we
really are trying oh and see look he
immediately starts fighting for us so
that guy this poor dude over here this
guy's got crucio on him we imperio this
guy and then he starts attacking the
dude that's crucio
oh my goodness now see now if they could
also put a curse on this guy here and
then start casting damaging spells on
him that would apply to all of the
others
oh it applies to all the others
mod that terms all screams into the will
Wilhelm scream this looks dark for real
right
portkey also travels with you oh so did
they not did they actually just get
absorbed into the book I mean I was
definitely getting Vibes of um
definitely getting Vibes of Tom Riddle's
Diary
okay so yeah so so it stays there
to their point right there about the the
port key deal
all right so combat all right hold on
hold on
I'm gonna I gotta put up a poll here
I gotta start a poll
favorite part of the Showcase
all right so option one we're gonna say
broom flight slash exploration
option two we're going to say Advanced
combat
option three we're going to say room of
requirement I got a feeling I know how
this is gonna go
oh I'm gonna make it harder on you guys
though
I'm gonna make it harder
I'm gonna also add as a fourth option
the varium to nurture
beasts I'm gonna make it not so easy for
you all right so favorite part of the
Showcase broom flight exploration that's
one Advanced combat two room of
requirement three or four vivarium to
nurture beasts boom all right vote in
the poll guys let me know what you think
let me know what you think if you
haven't already make sure to leave a
like on this video if you've enjoyed
hanging out with us today that's going
to help more people find the stream
everything was so good Nico for real
dude for real like I am uh I usually try
and be pretty what's the word not
critical but fair you know I want to be
fair I want to talk about the good talk
about the bad
um my initial gut reaction without going
through and looking at everything in
super fine detail I mean this this was
10 out of 10 for me 10 out of 10. I
thought what they showed was it was
incredible just incredible
all right let's just we can talk I want
to talk with you guys for a bit I mean I
want to get in here and break down but I
want to I want to see what you guys are
saying too so I'm just gonna let this
play here let's actually let's get some
music going in the background
and then I'm gonna I'm just gonna let
this exploration bit play here now that
we've got it in 4k
oh my good look at this look at this
you can talk about spells again so
pretty sure that's incendio on the right
I think that's our first time seeing the
icon for that one
agreed 10 out of 10.
Elwyn I love my beasts but flight dude
it's amazing Alicia favorite part was
the mooncalf where's the all option nah
go ninja I'm not option five yes Blue
Moon says no no I'm gonna Force you guys
to pick
Force you guys to pick all right we got
actually okay I'm a little bit surprised
but it I think it's because I made it
hard on you guys top top of our list
right now we've got 170 votes in the
poll 30 said broom flight exploration uh
27 saying room of requirement 24 saying
Advanced combat 19 saying the vivarium
to nurture beasts and it is rapidly
changing as the votes come in
rapidly changing as the votes come in
foreign
oh my gosh see this is what I wanted to
see dude this is what I wanted to see
all this in the Glorious 4K resolution
it looks so much better now
right there hopping onto the broom
hey Brandon welcome thank you for
subscribing to the channel also uh
surface magician subscribing thank you
for subscribing to the channel and then
in engineer
sorry I'm I'm definitely mispronouncing
that engine y lrm thank you for
subscribing
uh Casey with another Super Chat Casey
said you should put an all I everybody
it would have been 100 all it would have
been 100 all
we got him we gotta make it a little bit
different for you guys you know Casey
thank you so much for the Super Chat
thank you
let's see what else we got here
Larry the Cable man dude you missed so
much what are you talking about Larry
you talking about in the trailer are you
talking about donations or chats
Sonny law love your channel keeps me
sane until the game comes out hey thank
you Sunny Law thank you for the support
as well combat for real looks so fun
that was our best look yet I think we're
gonna be able to make some pretty
Advanced videos now breaking down all
the combat
so what I think is super interesting as
they're flying around here all these
little challenges that kept popping up
so I guess that's kind of like an area
thing like based on the location you're
in and then all these random NPCs oh
dude wait wait wait
there's a sign right up here right here
oh yes you know we got to zoom in on
this
okay we've got Hogwarts and lower
hogsmeade here to the right
can definitely read those two this one I
cannot read at all oh this side's what I
really want to know though
this side's what I really want to know
let's see what just popped in there wait
we had Elwyn with the Super Chat did I
miss Elwyn James confirmed it with proof
book in the clip is the book in the
collector's edition he's about to cry
oh you love to see it
you love to see it and then also right
on the back of elwin's uh donation there
we had Leisure knot with another soup
Jack gonna spend a lot of time
customizing my room of requirement
amphavarium right
dude people are gonna spend so much time
just customizing those two areas
that's the kind of thing when they first
showed that in the
in the state of play when they first
showed that
I never expected something like that
and then I I had a feeling I was like
okay
I think this is going to be a lot deeper
than people are thinking what does this
say right here k-e-e
is this an actual Village name near
Hogwarts
you guys let me know if it is
still nothing on Dementors yeah Luna
Comics still haven't seen anything onto
mentors
memories from the past
uh J Ross he said I did hear a gentleman
saying going through your year
uh Wolfie with a super chat as well this
absolutely blew my mind right Wolfie I'm
right there with you
right there with you
thank you guys for the super chats thank
you by the way what was my favorite part
I see sunny I was hoping people would
wait a second before confronting me with
it
oh man like it's hard for me
[Music]
if I had to pick one if I had to pick
one obviously I like all of them just
like you guys but if I had to pick one
I almost it's it's between exploration
and the combat
I think I'm gonna go exploration
actually I think I would say exploration
if I had to pick just one
Blue Man picked broom flight because
what we saw opened my eyes to the
extensive scope of this game 100 Blue
Moon uh other topics were partly
expected but also even more mind-blowing
at the same time crazy good shotis right
it was a crazy tease uh Christopher what
is crazy's level of customization to
those areas yes
like they could have they could have
just stopped like oh this is an area
where you can nurture Beast or this is
the area where you brew potions and this
is set like that's what I thought the
first time we went into that requirement
it's like oh all of this is how it's
gonna be but no you can customize all of
it
you can customize it
not just like oh a few Furniture items
you can customize the actual roof above
your head the window the color who knows
what else that they didn't show they
said this they said multiple times that
this is like scratching the surface are
you kidding me right now
I think this sign down here at the
bottom by the way says something about
trolls caution trolls
in whatever this area is
uh zoro's wolf of death yo thank you for
the Super Chat Zorro retro please join
me in the dark side dark magic has so
many more perks of being the good guy
right they haven't showed us much about
about being the good guy yet Alan
started to touch on it he started to
touch on it
and then they cut him off they didn't
let him
come on show us if we if we choose not
to go to the dark side you know what are
we gonna have at our disposal what are
we gonna have
because I mean I can't lie with what
Zorro's saying here the dark side's
looking pretty fun right now it's
looking pretty fun
now they they did also say that that
whole Arena I I guess I don't know if
that's any Arena or if it's just the
dark arts battle arena I I would assume
it would just be the dark arts because
that's one's name dark arts battle arena
even if you don't
choose to learn those spells like if you
want to play as like the good
playthrough or whatever you can go in
there just to experiment with them play
around have fun so
I love that they're doing that that's a
great option to have for those of us who
are like I want to stay true to the good
at least on my first playthrough right
stay true to the good
free Allen yes free Allen let Alan just
talk with us for hours on end
Professor Drew what is up I know it's
supposed to be op shouldn't the AK curse
be dodgeable by enemies seems like the
cutscene makes it a guarantee oh I
wonder like is yeah is that a cutscene
or is there a way for them to kind of
Dodge out of the way
it does look like it kind of shifts into
a cut scene there when you pull back to
cast it that's a good question I don't
know
but yeah you feel like they should at
least be able to hop out of the way now
see what I loved about this scene right
here like look at this we got a locked
door another locked door over here and
then we have this this kid just kind of
riding around on a pretend broom I love
it
and then we've got again some more
signage Brock burrow this way lower
hogsmeade this way
then they gave us a look right there oh
Aaron Aaron Shire
hogsmead
and then this one says graveyard
and then iron iron something on that one
and then Danger
oh we don't get to see what danger Boo
looks like it says danger and then
starts with a B
Horizon zero Dawn Vibes with the
atmosphere walking around I could see
that uh Zorro says all right I have to
go sorry retro a Zorro all good
appreciate you stopping by and hanging
out hope you enjoyed the stream
appreciate your your support in the
Super Chat by the way guys this VOD will
stay up I know a lot of people are like
taking breaks at work and stuff so this
this will stay live on the channel you
guys can go back and re-watch anytime
anything that you missed let me know in
the comments below replay Squad if you
go back and watch but um for those of
you who have to bounce out and leave
thank you so much for being here
um we're gonna keep breaking it down
here for a little bit longer here but
yeah they don't really give us a great
look at the uh that last sign right
there danger something I can see
ah
invincibility frames uh hold on I want
to make sure I don't miss that no way
we're either getting damaged nor the
enemy is escaping
so like we're Invincible I see what you
mean
it could be I could see that maybe some
powerful enemies will be able to dodge
or something like that I mean the way
Alan talked it seems like the way
they're balancing AK is with the um
with the cooldown
now we also don't know like they were
talking about potions I'm gonna have to
re-watch we only watched it one time but
they were talking about Potions there
and other things that you can use to
like I think it was combos also speed up
how quick you get it back now we also
don't know if it's different in the dark
arts battle arena like maybe it
recharges faster there
did they say that Patronus charm will
not be in the game they have not said it
will not be in the game
they haven't said they have not said
anything about the Patronus
the reason that people started
speculating is because uh oh wait now
that chair right there that is showing
oh but I wonder if that's interact like
for an object for a pugno
I wonder I wonder
all right they walk over here to the
chair because I know people are going to
be asking can you not sit at the bar can
you not sit down at the table yeah it
doesn't look like any interact pops up
now there is oh the chairs are still
clearly this chair was highlighted and
then this one got highlighted so maybe
you can go sit over here
because they clearly walk over here take
a drink
and then there's an interact right there
on the middle of the table but I think
it might be for that
yeah it's for the object it's for the
mug right there
yeah so the only reason people started
speculating about the Patronus is
because when they confirmed that you can
link your Wizarding World account
they didn't say Patronus so that's why a
lot of people were like ah
Professor Drew retro you should be the
host of the third showcase I mean we'll
see if there is a third right
I kind of feel like I would have already
been contacted by now
but who knows who knows
see
uh Umbra I missed everything oh don't
you worry don't you worry umber we're
gonna have a lot of uh breakdown videos
for sure
live and replay squad for Nico let's go
Ellen literally gonna be spending all
day watching the live streams I know
right I gotta go back I want to see I
want to see everybody's reactions to uh
all the random moments there were so
many moments in this one
so many moments of epicness
wonder what the screen shows if we die
oh wait hold on speaking of moments of
epicness
dude let's just appreciate this
I said it in the live stream I'll say it
again Avalanche whoever's idea was to
have this little bag right here okay now
wait
we don't see
we're gonna start trying to figure out
which button does this which button
summons our mount
whoever's idea it was to have the mount
be like this needs a race give this
person a raise watch this you guys watch
this
are you kidding me
that is just so epic right there
Ellen with another Super Chat we have
over 550 people here watching let's go
guys thank you for the love and support
for being here today if you can please
like the video stream show your love
thank you Ellen for the Super Chat and
thank you guys man so many people for
being here hanging out even after the
Showcase uh but yeah if you do have the
time if you're enjoying the stream make
sure to leave a like helps more people
find the video
um so we can get more people uh in here
excited about this game
I gotta watch this again dude
so good
oh I didn't even catch this on the first
viewing the goats over here now they
talked about how you can um
it seems like with the hippogriff you
could just run along on the ground for a
bit
oh wait maybe is you think right on the
d-pad could be summon
or it might be just be dismount
how would a bogart work in the game if
it's in the game
I have no idea unless I I think if a
bogart was in the game they'd have to
base it around like our character's
backstory it'd have to be related to
something in our in our past
Karthik retro on the third showcase I'm
screaming my lungs thank you Karthik
we'll see we'll see attention to detail
is so crazy everything has a different
animation I mean this right
everything they showed here was awesome
today but this alone like just seeing
all this stuff that we're going to be
able to explore all the stuff that keeps
popping up all the little markers on the
map oh I did want to deposit during the
live stream but look at this the tool
wheel L1 is useful for dealing with
higher level combat situations combat
plants and Potions can give you an
advantage against tougher enemies okay
so I thought it was going to have
something to do with the flight right
here Dylan do you think we can swim
keep going back and forth on it Dylan I
keep going back and forth
we tried to summon it last night during
our live stream we tried to make it
happen just like we made the jump button
happen a lot of people are asking for
swimming
some days I feel like yes some days I
feel like no like maybe it's gonna be
just feel like that'd be so much to
program like the underwater component
you know now maybe they have it like
where you can swim but you can't like
like dive deep down possibly
100 on board with quidditch and chess
being future DLC after seeing this
showcase totally okay with their
decisions here yeah like I knew they
would have to have some things for and
then I love this little like how you can
stop and kind of do this hover
look at all these icons here we're gonna
have to figure out what all of these
mean
levitate a dug bog by its stuff
all these little challenges that are
popping up dude
slow a loyalist assassin right there
this is gonna be one of those games that
everyone plays forever oh I hope so man
I hope we can just sync hours and hours
and hours into this
uh Christopher if you were worried they
would show too much of the game in these
streams I think we now see just how much
there will be to do yeah yeah like for
this I love I love seeing stuff like
this
I know some people don't and you know
that's your that's your choice right if
you don't want to watch them
fine right you don't have to but I think
I mean Chandler said I've seen him
replying to people on Twitter they're
being very careful about what they're
showing the only stuff I care about not
seeing is uh like like story stuff dude
I didn't even catch on the live stream
it started to rain a little bit right
there I don't know if it's because
they're just going through that area or
what but it definitely started to rain
yeah it seems like that's a certain area
on the map that is not uh not too
Pleasant
no way there's going to be all three
unforgivables but not the Patronus
charmer right Kitty right
especially if you're going to have
Dementors we have to have a way of
combating those Dementors we have to
Patronus charm make it happen
I feel like Patronus charm is in like
maybe it's something that um
so that happens toward the end I don't
know
Pokemon wheat's Wizarding World right
uh so we saw Dementors in the first
trailer for the game in a cut scene
I love this part this is funny the dev
Dev commands and then we and then the
mentors are on the deluxe box art which
which to me
think they have to be in right they have
to be in at some point
after what I'm seeing I don't doubt 150
Patronus wouldn't be that hard
especially when most are muggle animals
or others others already have model
creatures in the game just add bluish
transparency it true true
clearly they've had to program a lot of
animations because that was one of my
sort of reservations about bringing it
over from The Wizarding World is I
thought it would probably be too much
um programming work like for all the
different animations on there but
to your point there maybe they already
have a lot of them because of
what they've done here
Tom retro was just trying to sneak out
some Hogwarts objects
from the shelves there oh I must be
behind Tyler yo Tyler with a super chat
Tyler thank you so much for your support
of the stream and the Super Chat there I
didn't see any question
um so hopefully you didn't have a
question there if you do just post it in
the chat and I'll I'll try to catch it
there
hippogriff shiny right goat animal
therefore easy goat Patronus
uh Road Not Taken I'd say it'll
definitely support both controller
options
dude wait hold on there was like a
bonfire back here
I'm gonna I mean we're gonna keep
catching stuff as we
I'm pretty sure they fly over some
wolves or something right here wait what
is what is that
they cut away
you could sort of see our little uh
it kind of like locks on I hope you can
disable that
hope you can disable that little HUD
element maybe that's for like the story
mode
what was that I'm pretty sure we see
wolves a little bit later
but then right there there's like this
bonfire right here in this little
I don't know this little Shack
oh wait this could be a look at that
little skull symbol right there
that could be like an area that we need
to um
I don't know what's what's the right
word
free that area or whatever
reveal the L1 use potions use right
right
they went close to the to the water with
the hippocrife but didn't touch it
still need to confirm swim and sit maybe
get a mount that can swim I like that
this game looks like red dead 2. I
wasn't gonna say it but I thought the
same thing Chris black I definitely had
a little bit of a red dead Vibe when
they when they went outside there
do you think you can have your Mount as
your pet
hmm what do you mean by that Marcus like
could you get the mount in the vivarium
area
it's an interesting question I'm not
sure about that
like are the who yeah like are the
mounts that emerge from our little bag
can you also like take them out in the
bavarium and play fetch with them and
all that feed them care for them
aren't your spells to breathe underwater
all right there's Gilly weed yeah yeah
swim could be like the old Assassin's
Creed games only surface level swimming
just holding breath underwater I could
see that yeah
yeah Amanda they did confirm holidays
and changing of decorations like within
hogsmead as well as uh in the castle
Yeah
they said holidays so I'm thinking
like Thanksgiving is just a U.S thing
for the most part so that one's not I'm
thinking probably Halloween
Christmas
those are probably the big two
because I'm trying to think of like the
big holidays in the books
something always happens to the books on
Halloween something always major
uh did you catch at some point
Chandler said through your year at
Hogwarts feel like that confirms just
one year I did not catch that Rusty
that's a good that's a great catch
somebody else mentioned that earlier I
think I've been saying for a while like
one year is kind of my gut so that
that's that's what I'm expecting
new enemy types revealed the
enchantments-esque thing they showed
various enemy types oh I'm gonna have to
go back and check that out
uh I want swimming merfolk quidditch
golfstones wizard chess romance pet bat
oh my goodness all of the above for
Casey there
primordial I don't think so I don't
think they're gonna separate the spells
like that I think they're gonna separate
the Spells how Alan talked about in the
first Showcase with James with expecto
go uh they talked about there's combat
there's
um oh gosh help me out chat like
movement or something like force based
or something like that
there were three types and I think he
said there are four types and then he he
listed off three
like a poacher Camp yeah yeah Kelpie
Mount oh that would be cool
Luca says we will be able to swim for
sure Army of nibblers ghost of tsushima
vigil yeah I can see the inspiration of
that one as well
we reported on that a while back oh
here's another uh interrupt a charging
Mongrel with depulso
I mean to Allen's Point that's got to be
a Merlin thing right yeah that's one of
Merlin's which we saw so this icon right
here this little leaf
Merlin's puzzles
Merlin's puzzles for the little leaf
right there
yeah that's a good question Nico like
can we ride the grab horn and then
have it in the room of requirement yeah
can we just become an anime just at this
point animagus animagus
I still prefer uh animages but
I I I hesitate to say no to anything at
this point I really do I really hesitate
to say no to anything like my gut
instinct is probably no
but who the heck knows
who the heck knows after seeing what all
they included there in the bavariums and
in the room of requirement
yeah though the whopping Willow from the
Potter series wouldn't be here it wasn't
planted yet
uh however there could be other Whomping
Willows I made a whole video about that
gosh probably over a year ago now
there's a lot of confusion on that
people thought just saw my thumbnail and
thought I had it wrong I'm like no no
watch the video
so whopping Willow yes we that read the
books think of it as the Whomping Willow
but it's just it's just a type of plant
in The Wizarding World so there could be
others and there could be some here long
before Harry Potter's day for sure all
right so here they're making their way
into the dark arts battle arena which
let's hold on we gotta go back and let's
get a look at the thestral mount
animation
right here
this is this is like seriously one of my
favorite things
so good so good we already know you can
do that with a grab horn as well they
showed that at the event in Brazil
Kitty a giant Moon calf is my Patronus
bet you could turn into an anime just uh
you need to do the actual procedure fail
endless times until you get it right
if there is Merlin will there be more
Ghana
people ask me about the Merlin stuff too
like expect or go is definitely the uh
at least that's where I heard it first
of all the Merlin theories
so I'll defer to him on that I I still
lean more toward Merlin being like a
side thing
and possibly not as key to the story
or if it is it's like just some sort of
historical reference
oh let's read this right here I'm gonna
stop this here fight waves of enemies in
this battle arena with the unforgivable
curse okay so that's what the dark arts
ballerina which this one
I think is a deluxe only thing
they confirm there's going to be three
total battle arenas two that everyone
will get regardless of which version
then the dark arts battle arena is only
for
the um the the deluxe pre-orders Leisure
not with another Super Chat let's go
Leisure not thank you for all your
support today appreciate it my friend
and one of the clips from ccxp the
character summoned a grab horn and used
to run into enemies yes yes exactly they
summoned a grapplearn just like we saw
there with the thestral and then
basically just like charged over these
goblins and that looked like it was like
out in the Overworld area instead it was
crazy
crazy
fourth type of spells confirmed right
green is curses
you might be right yes because green
they are a different color in here
right there actually hold on that's more
than four
we see this sort of dark green here so
that's one the red is two the purple is
three then there's this lighter green
foreign
maybe the unforgivables have their so
wait these lighter spells are definitely
the unforgivables that's the three
unforgivables right there
you're a wizard we see those here in a
second
Henry Henry thank you for subscribing to
the channel
when they morph the bench I thought I I
thought the same thing Gabe I thought
the same thing
I thought the same thing Noob what's up
new with another Super Chat retro I did
it check Discord
Noob I don't have I don't even have
Discord loaded right now
too much too much to break down Noob too
much to break down right now
just immediately into the AK just
immediately
yeah I thought for sure they were gonna
sit down earlier too the dark green okay
wait
the dark green or the unforgivables you
think okay hold on so let's get it get a
good look right there that's the
coloration of the unforgivables here
and then we go back here to this blurred
out screen
they do look yeah because there's only
three of those but there's only three of
the lighter ones too
I think you're right though this green
definitely matches more with
and they this is how they have it set up
once they get in here it's these three
and then this one on the left which they
confirmed as confringo
Kitty hey Kitty thank you so much for
becoming a member here welcome you are
now a member of House wrecking tour you
can use the emotes in the chat
yeah so see right here I think you're
right I think it's the darker green
so darker green is for so maybe the
unforgivables have their own category
When Alan was talking about the category
of spells
maybe the unforgivables have different
strengths depending on which option you
choose uh Draco not just Deluxe
pre-orders you can buy the Dark Art
right good that's a good point Draco
yeah even if you bought the standard
version
um you do have the option of of
purchasing the upgrade to include it so
don't worry if you see it see people
plan it online or something and you
decide you want it you will have the
option afterwards
you will have the option good point
Draco thank you for bringing that up
Professor Drew so the unforgivable
curses are not allowed in the other
Arenas that makes sense I wonder how
much control there is in the in using in
the open world yeah so my guest Drew on
the um like I think this dark arts Arena
actually that's a good point do we know
that like does that confirm you can't
use them
I don't think it confirms that you can't
however what Alan did talk about is is
he talked about how if you don't want to
go down like the dark arts path or
whatever that this is kind of a way for
players to come in and experiment with
those spells I think
even if you don't learn them in game I
think that's what he said
we'll have to do our full breakdown
later but I think that's what he said
so then to your point I could see the
other battle arenas like you see games
do this a lot where they have these
little challenges and so when you're
doing these challenges you have to only
use one type of weapon or you know a
couple different types of weapons or you
have to eliminate enemies in a certain
way or
so with the dark arts win it's like all
about the unforgivables
so yeah I could see the other Arenas
being based around something else Noob
with another chat new
thank you so much for the sport Noob
light green healing or support spells
could be could be he's because Alan
stopped just short of explaining it in
the first gameplay showcase
I'm pretty sure he only listed off three
and they're all they're not coming to my
mind right now but he mentioned combat
so that means that that um
that AKA crucio and imperio are not in
the combat category they have their own
category for the unforgivables all right
so let's go back in here
let's jump back in to this section right
here
which we watched a little bit more
earlier so we know R1 is going to be for
a pug no there
six types of spells wait did I just
completely miscount
did I completely Miss count again Cole
all right so we got the red that's one
the dark green two
the light green three
the purple four and the yellow five
so one two three four
oh no wait wait
okay let's I think it's easier to look
at it this way yellow is one purple is
two red is three light blue is four the
light green is five and yeah then the
dark green would be six you're right
why can I not count today
so yeah then the unforgivables are in
their own category because they're the
dark green
oh that's super interesting
we're gonna have to go through and look
at all these two like see the different
things that they're
uh Henry will the game have romance I
don't think so Henry I think it'll be
more just like
um just like friendly relationships with
with fellow students I don't think it'll
be like going on dates or anything like
that
uh whole triangle during protego to stun
enemies with a stupefy counter-attack
okay wait so I thought
so is it just tap
so is it just tap triangle four protego
but then if you hold it if you keep
holding it down you stun enemies with a
stupefy counter-attack interesting
let's see if we see that happen at any
point well there's another crucio
another crucio on that guy
oh man the combat's gonna be so fun
it's gonna be so fun
yeah yeah you got it Cole you got it
okay Mary Mary's uh breaking them down
for tier unforgivables combat Essentials
and control
I do remember him talking about
essential spells that would be things
like uh like the little triangle with
the eye here that was um
revelio that you that you can have
access to at any time left on the d-pad
rivelio
and we also got confirmation guys of how
it works between switching out your
different categories here so they've got
the the Spells right here did you see
that look at that look at that they just
switched to four different spells
so the way man I wish I could get this
little this YouTube bar to disappear
right here
I'm gonna have to let it play as soon as
I move my mouse I'm pretty sure this
reappears but just watch the bottom
right you guys watch the bottom right
you see that there's the d-pad right
there so you hold R2
and then pressing on the d-pad in a
certain direction allows you to switch
to a different set of spells very
quickly we were wondering how that would
be handled after the last time oh and I
want to see how this works right here
too okay
I thought I caught this live
let's watch that combo meter
the combo meter wait why does it jump up
all of a sudden it's at 12.
but it is at kind of this like halfway
point so maybe that means you can use it
because they look over here at that
wizard right there and this l1r1 pops up
has kind of this blue little silhouette
on it I definitely think that is
connected
to the combo right here to the ancient
magic we see that light up and then we
see that spell right there yeah and Alan
even let's see if this is what he's
talking about right here
because he he mentioned the ancient
magic change the way you play and I
think Mackenzie knows a lot about what's
going on with the plants and potions and
so the
this is what Elwyn caught during the
stream they just uh changed this is this
is not the part where Alan said what I
was looking for but L when caught this
during the stream this whatever this
ancient magic ability right here is it
transformed this dude into a a chicken
what oh my goodness
anime King thank you for subscribing to
the channel
oh my gosh
wholesome evil changed my mind favorite
part of the Showcase when they were
dancing during the transition Right Dark
Arts arena is if you want to be a good
wizard
okay right right that's what I was
thinking
that's what I was thinking
I think so too Karthik I think there's
more for ancient magic I mean in fact
we've seen it with the big lightning
strike
or or perhaps a different one is
unlocked if you fill this meter all the
way because they did this little trans
figure wait does this confirm
Transfiguration in the game
or is that going to be part of our
ancient magic oh maybe fig is our
Transfiguration professor and also
teaching us ancient Magic
I don't know don't know just throwing
out stuff just throwing out stuff that's
how these ideas come to me you guys
that's how they come to me
but yeah right here chicken
can you believe this
uh most likely dog low yes most likely
probably even the seventh if they if
they'll allow streams on the 7th for the
Early Access
wonderful meet any students oh that
aren't Anna anime guy
well I'm thinking that Sebastian's
sister is a maledictus
so that that's not exactly what you're
asking there but Lucas wonder what
difficulty this is I would say it's on
one of the easier difficulties
either story mode or easy that's usually
how they do these types of things
usually they don't they don't show off
the hardest difficulty just like across
the board hit a troll with its own
Boulder and defeat an enemy with a
venomous tentacula okay we I don't think
we saw this during the live stream
because we had the captions going
enemies have a higher level than you
will be harder to defeat
makes sense makes sense
uh Draco didn't they say you could go
so Draco
that was my oh I gotta pull that back up
that was my interpretation Draco is that
left d-pad that you could change what
that spell is but I'm not sure if I was
correct in that so they to answer your
question they did not outright say that
no that's kind of what I got from how
Alan described it in the Showcase number
one but I think I might be incorrect on
that I think I might be
chicken power like Moody with the ferret
I know right dude more like a rooster
handy chicken if you need a mid-fight uh
snack kiddo BP welcome kiddo thank you
for being here and hanging out
that it tastes like a ferret
chicken spell a nod to realm Royale
uh Tom you think they have a different
variation of blocks meaning if you
perfectly time it causes a faster
Refresh on your other spells could be
could be yeah I tried to stop this one
right oh dude wait what is this
what is this menu right here
is this the L1
no I think because L1 is what
I feel like L1 is what would use that
potion over there on the left so then
what causes this menu right here what do
they press to get that to appear
yeah grabhorn has the mount for sure for
sure because we saw that in the uh
Brazilian Comic-Con
and it looked awesome just like the
others mounts are L1 then d-pad possibly
uh Karthik my point in the AKA having
invisibility frames when he casts on the
first troll troll is about to attack AK
was activated and the troll just stopped
the attack
oh okay that's not how I was taking it
yeah I'll have to go back and watch that
that isn't that is really interesting
though if it's um
oh release oh want to equip there you go
thanks guys so yeah they're holding L1
down to bring this menu up
yeah that's kind of oh that makes it
even more op right if an enemy is about
to attack you hit AK you start your
animation and they just they just
instantly stop what they're doing that'd
be kind of weird but again this could be
we don't know about difficulty settings
and we don't know how it will actually
play in the final game yeah so release
to equip so I wonder if you just if you
tap L1 doesn't just use it holding L1
brings up this and then you see the
right stick here to go around and select
so I know they talked about wig and weld
potion I think that's this one right
here Chinese chomping cabbage release L1
to equip so if you release L1 that
equips it
and then we've got our Mandrake here
venomous tentacula here and a blue
potion here that might be the rock
potion they show here in a little bit
and then three that are locked and then
also we see the mounts over here on the
right dude I'm just saying there's a
fourth space here open
oh wait would that be hippogriff though
oh man does this kill our hopes of a
dragon
I'm not giving up Hope on a dragon mount
not giving up hope
I'm not giving up hope yet we were
wondering last night next to the map
yes exactly Ellen yes so I think this
pretty much confirms that this this
means you cannot use your mount in this
area this little like invalid symbol
so if I have this right holding L1 will
bring up this menu
and so I guess over here maybe you can
change which mount
I bet you could set one Mount to a
hotkey
something on the d-pad maybe and then if
you want to do one of the other mounts
you can like hold L1 and go here to
select it or change the hotkey
oh dude wait I want to see what that I
didn't read the description down there
at the bottom
[Music]
um so formidable chomping cabbages that
when released attack nearby enemies
chomping cabbages cabbage seeds can be
purchased at dogweed and death cap must
be grown in medium or large pots this
game is so deep this game is so deep
Casey with another Super Chat Casey
thank you so much for your support what
if we play as a descendant of merlot
right I mean that's been
that's been expecto goes big theory for
a while
we shall see oh and look at that they
try to switch away quickly
we're gonna go frame by frame here
though we're gonna get back to it
oh come on
come on troll
there it is oh this one's called a focus
potion
so they did talk about that one too that
one will reduce the drinker's spell
cooldowns it lasts for 15 seconds so you
get like a 15 second boost I guess and
how fast your spells are are cooling
down so Brewing time this one takes one
minute to brew it will yield one bottle
you need one lacewing fly one flux weed
stem and one Doug bog tongue
for for uh making that one
all right let's check on the the poll
results guys we had over 500 votes in
the poll
favorite part of the Showcase
the broom flight and exploration came
out on top at 33 Advanced combat was
right behind it at 26 and then room of
requirement right behind it at 25 and
then vivarium to nurture the beast at
15. I think we could probably add this
two together
give us a 40 so room of requirement
overall would have been people's Top
Choice
oh man
but but just seeing that breakdown right
there tells you
how great everything was that they
showed right I mean the fact that people
were so hyped about all of that
oh then you get the little so I wonder
if the red oh it's different color
indicators I wonder if the red means
unblockable they may have confirmed this
and I was just so hyped in the middle
that I didn't hear it like I'm playing
through God of War right now and the red
when you see red on the enemy attacks it
means unblockable so you notice they
Dodge out of the way on this one they
don't even try protego now that one was
a different color and then they tried
protego dude I bet that's totally what
it is oh I love this right here I love
this dude
watch this so they cast they get they
get it to cool dude look how fast a
vodka diver refills when they use that
potion it is so fast so you get red you
gotta Dodge red again or oh wait hold on
hold on I'm gonna get it right this time
all right red Dodge red again Dodge and
then this one is like a slightly
yellowish
that one means you can protego boom
there's potato right there break that
attack a pug no right to the face 709
damage then we just do our basic shot
now we got AK fully charged ready to go
boom troll is done
oh my gosh this combat is gonna be so
fun
it was Levitate by the Tongue right
if there's no romance is there no love
potion
probably not
probably not who knows though like I'm
I'm not putting limits on anything at
this point given how much they have
wowed us today uh we've got challenges
right here cast stupefied an enemy
defeat an enemy with a Chinese Chomp and
cabbage perform a dueling combo one out
of 30.
uh there's the spell icon for confringo
which they confirm that too
so a pug no by the way is R1 we've known
that for a while we get com more
confirmation of that
today
all right now remember last time Alan
talked about the shields so you got the
red shield right here which means that
our character needs to cast confringo
here or really any red
spell to get rid of that
so right here you see he's gonna stand
up he's got that red shield going there
was wait was that
the confringo kind of looked a little
bit
that animation looked a little bit odd
right there I don't know if that's oh no
they cast confringo on this dude over
here
and then this one right here
I thought he said we would have to use a
red spell
maybe I misunderstood him last time
because it looks like we take that
shield down by getting that quick
deflect
and then we did we just did we just
crucial
oh my gosh I'm gonna have to watch that
in more detail I'm still not 100 sure
what what's happened just a basic shot
that one could be red too so maybe it's
protego if you protego and and do the
wait a second
just a minute ago we read the part about
how
if you if you hold triangle after
casting protego that it will fire off
Stupify
it will fire Stupify
so I bet that it you hold triangle it
does a quick stupefy back breaks the red
shield so Stupify probably qualifies as
the uh
as a combat spell of course
another thing I noticed unforgivable
spells break all Shields even the red
purple and yellow interesting
Noob can be like Palpatine I play Both
Sides at the same time
uh the female developer's name her laugh
was infectious she loves seeing Ben's
reactions right she didn't get to I
don't feel like she'd talk I would I
would have loved to have heard more from
her that's what everybody said about
Boston last time though too like let us
hear more from Boston
what was her name again he got Alan and
then another Hufflepuff McKenzie system
designer I totally forgot to look at at
the house
another Hufflepuff McKenzie toner
all right back back to the dark arts
Arena here
loyalist assassin
all right that's the part we just saw
he used imperio to break the shield it
said that unforgivable curses break
Shields okay that's what you guys were
just saying yeah
so I guess unforgivable Unforgivable s
to straight up break everything
they just break everything man
I could tell people are going to be
spending a lot of time in this dark arts
battle arena I feel like it's gonna be
the one where people just going on the
power trip just going crazy man aking
beasts goblins humans left and right
crucial I can't believe crucial is like
we know it's a dark spell from the books
you wonder how much they would lean into
that with with the T rating but dude
it's dark you're like those horrified
Whispers man it's crazy
and then you've got the uh the armored
troll dropping in here
wait let's watch that again because I
think we get another yeah they're
dodging every time on the red and then
when you get the the yellowish gold one
they protego that
War Machine can't wait for this game to
come out dude it looks
looks it right oh man it looks so good
all right so guys we are coming to the
end of the stream here but before we go
I want to say that we do this every week
we just had one last night and obviously
on the next stream we're gonna have much
to discuss if you guys are just dropping
in if you've never seen my videos before
we post a ton of Hogwarts like to see
videos here on the channel check them
out of course in the next few days we're
gonna have I don't even know what I'm
gonna tackle first I have no idea what
video I'm gonna make first because
there's so many details here that we're
gonna have to break down but you can
look forward to those videos
uh and yeah join us on Tuesday nights
guys live stream every Tuesday night
around 8pm Eastern Time
and we're gonna have plenty more news in
the lead up to Hogwarts Legacy we also
have a Discord you can join that
exclamation point Discord in the chat
we'll get you the information for that
honestly I'd stay here all day and
stream I'd stay here all day but uh I
gotta get back to my my regular nine to
five job
gotta get back to my regular but thank
you all so much for being here uh if you
catch us on the replay or even if you're
watching now make sure to leave a like
Elwyn said we head over do we have over
500 L one
over 530 people here oh my goodness I
hate to leave with 530 people here
oh man I hate to leave with 530 people
but I gotta run it's been a lot of fun
guys thank you all so much for choosing
I know there's a lot of streams and a
lot of places you can watch
thank you so much for being here it
really does mean a lot
um you can follow me on Twitter at retro
wrecking tour again the Discord
exclamation point Discord we'll see it
there you can continue the conversation
there's just gonna be so much to discuss
here in the in the coming days and weeks
in the lead-up to this game because it
has officially gone gold uh it'll be
here before you know it man it will be
here before you know it so make sure you
guys take some time to enjoy the ride uh
and it was good seeing some new faces in
here especially all the people who don't
normally get to tune in when we do our
uh
our evening streams because that we have
a worldwide audience so I know the
timing doesn't work for everybody but
guys thank you so much for being here
um I'm gonna go ahead and we'll play a
little music here in the outro but um
thank you all for being here and I'll
talk to you again very soon
foreign
[Music]
[Music]